[Music]
foreign
[Music]
this is talk TV
[Music]
tonight at Hollywood Superstar Alec
Baldwin to be charged with involuntary
manslaughter after fatally shooting a
cinematographer on his movie Set we'll
have live reaction from America on
Baldwin's legal fight and for what may
be left of his career
thus defeating wokeness with debate
comedian Constantine kissing became a
global sensation this week after taking
on the Oxford Union students he joins me
live on his fight for free speech
live from London this is Piers Morgan
uncensored well good evening from London
and welcome to Pittsburgh on a sense of
breaking news in the last couple of
hours 15 months ago Alec Baldwin shot
dead a female cinematographer on the set
of rust a movie he was starring in and
producing the death of Helena Hutchins
is one of the most appalling tragedies
in Hollywood history now there was no
doubt that it was an accident but Helena
Hutchins died leaving behind a
grief-stricken husband and a young child
and the person holding the gun that
fired a bullet that killed her was Ali
Baldwin it was him that did that he
fired the bullet into his co-worker's
Bud body and snuffed out her life nobody
else's hands were even near the gun but
since that tragic day Baldwin's been the
epitome of Hollywood arrogance he's
embarked on a woeful self-pitying PR
tour that felt cynically designed to
make people feel he was just as much of
a victim as the woman he killed he's
repeatedly spewed indignant denial of
any responsibility to his millions of
followers on social media and in a
succession of Television interviews
here's what he told ABC News
do you feel guilt no no I feel that
there is I I feel that that that that
someone is responsible for what happened
and I can't say who that is but I know
it's not me no guilt at all even though
he was literally holding the gun that
fired the bullet that killed this woman
not a shred of personal responsibility
accountability or guilt here he is
addressing his fans
I wanted to take a moment to
say thank you to all of the people who
sent me such kind words and uh
you know best wishes and strength and
hope and prayers and so forth and
thoughts and lots of encouragement and
lots of really really great
um
sentiments from so many people I got
hundreds hundreds of emails from friends
and family and colleagues and people
that I
and some I hadn't heard from in quite a
while to send me a
strength and good wishes and so forth
and I'm very grateful for that I want to
say thank you to everybody and online on
Instagram many people commenting
sorry
you haven't just won an Oscar
I saw that speed sounded like didn't it
an Oscar Redemption speech
no it's his real life it's not a film a
young woman was killed
well today Santa Fe prosecutors
announced that he Alec Baldwin and the
film's armorer a young woman called
Hannah Gutierrez read will be charged
with involuntary manslaughter both face
up to 18 months in jail if they're
convicted but Baldwin should a form
issued a statement through his attorney
striking a familiar tone
this decision distorts Helena hutchin's
tragic death represents a terrible
miscarriage of Justice his lawyers said
Mr Baldwin had no reason to believe
there was a live bullet in the gun or
anywhere on the movie Set we will fight
these charges and we will win well we'll
see about that because that's not what
the prosecutor thinks here's what the
prosecutor said
we've talked to many actors
um A-list and otherwise that have said
that they always check their guns or
they have someone check it in front of
them so it's not an actor doesn't get a
free pass just because they're an actor
and that's what's so important is that
we're saying here in New Mexico
everyone's equal under the law everyone
has to follow their duties and do what's
right and take that safety into account
so that this doesn't ever happen again
well that's right that's what I hear
from actors too they all check if
they're firing a firearm in any capacity
on a movie set they all check just for
their own sake never mind anybody else's
there's no live ammunition or anything
wrong with this weapon that they're
using Alec Baldwin's done a lot of
talking a lot of self-protective talking
a lot of spinning a lot of denial of any
accountability or responsibility well
his next words on this matter will be in
a court of law
let's discuss uh Baldwin's legal fight
we've got some American legal experts
coming shortly but I want to talk first
of all to lawyer Paula Roan Adrian talk
to the international editor Isabella
shot and talk to your presenter Richard
Tice this is a very emotive story
Richard
but it is hard I think you've got
Classic Hollywood response to a real
story you've got a kind of almost
fictional response like he's in a movie
Alec Baldwin and all that really matters
is that he comes through triumphant in
some way I.E without any blame for any
of this and yet at the heart of it is a
real woman really killed absolutely but
there are two separate things there's
his shocking appalling totally
inexcusable response as you've just
explained there but the reality is this
is a tragic tragic accident and as I
understand you never have live
ammunition on a set so why on Earth
would he expect that there would be I
think what it shows though is this is
classic America someone's always to
blame you've got to sue someone you've
got to put him in jail I think that's
the wrong approach it's a tragic
accident learn from it make sure For
Heaven's Sake it never never happens
again but why go through all of this
process I just think that's I think his
his his response has been completely
intensive but what do you achieve by
well actually what you achieve what you
achieve is for the poor woman's husband
and their young child what you achieve
is is accountability for the death of
this woman yeah I mean to me
sorry she was killed because there was a
complete breakdown of safety on the set
and I think probably it wasn't just the
star of the movie he was also a
co-producer of the movie and has
produced the responsibilities for what
is going on so that feels to me like the
charge is the wrong one
um I think you will know because
involuntary manslaughter means that you
kill somebody we didn't deliberately
mean to it I think you were uni harsh on
him I I mean really I accept that his PR
skills lead some leave something to be
desired I think his responses there are
pretty woeful and undoubtedly a part of
the reason he is where he is now facing
these charges but at the end of the day
you've got an actor on a set he must
have been in this position a thousand
times before he had no reason to expect
that gum was loaded someone handed him a
loaded gun hean was entitled to assume
that it was for the for the for the film
that it wasn't loaded with
ammunitions do you make assumptions when
you're dealing with
statement that we just listened to but
actually on film sets there is a
procedure and that most actors in that
situation do make a final check
themselves but also in most film sets
there's never ever live ammunition right
anywhere near the film but again why
would it again he is a producer with
responsibility for that as well let's go
to Joseph Tully he's a criminal defense
lawyer in America won a number of
high-profile gun cases himself in the
past Mr Tully what do you think of this
because you know emotions are running
higher about it but what is the cold
hard legal reality of where Alec Baldwin
finds himself
so the cold hard legal reality is that
you can't be convicted of a crime where
you shouldn't be convicted of a crime
unless there's some kind of criminal
culpability so if this was an accident
then he should be found not guilty
um if there was negligence that amounts
to criminal negligence then he would be
found guilty of something
um however I I regardless of what people
think of of Hollywood actors and and
their attitude uh towards others as his
PR skills have you know we've seen from
his PR skills
um I I don't think that there's criminal
liability here I mean it's an
interesting call that because the
prosecutor was very strong in her
wording today and said nobody's Above
the Law clearly wanting to distance the
whole sort of Hollywood aspect to this
from what has happened here uh Santa Fe
of course a place where a lot of people
know how to use guns gun ownership is
very prevalent there so a jury I suspect
maybe quite actually quite tough I think
on a bunch of Hollywood actors being a
you know indiscriminately irresponsible
around guns which clearly happened here
um the real question becomes how
responsible was he personally for not
being aware that this gun had a a bull
in it I don't for a moment imagine he
knew so let's park that to one side and
I think anybody thinks that but as a
co-producer of the show which had
already had a number of safety issues
including several days before this
incident that had been raised where
people actually leaving the set in
protest at the lack of safety he's
responsible as a co-producer for the
general safety on that said I would
argue and secondly every actor I've
talked to has been involved in a gun
scene like this in a movie or a TV show
has said to me that they always always
will check themselves as a Fail-Safe at
the end just in case and he clearly
didn't do that either
well he he did ask about the gun and he
was told that it was a cold gun meaning
that the gun was not but he didn't check
you physically himself
correct yes so he relied on someone else
who handed him the gun and was informed
that it was a cold God so does it the
question is does that amount to criminal
negligence not physically checking
himself when he relied on somebody else
who is a professional whose job it is is
to ensure that uh accidents do not
happening except then sorry to jump in
but except the armor in this case he's
also been charged was 24 years old an
absolute rookie doing this kind of thing
on a movie set and again it comes back
to his dual role of star but also
co-producer I would argue there's almost
a charge of negligence in putting a
rookie armorer in charge of this
situation which then led to the death of
this woman
that is maybe the best argument that the
prosecution will have
um if he didn't do a background check if
he overlooked several instances of her
uh being negligent on set or producing a
a dangerous happenstance then I think
then we go more towards uh him being
liable however if he uh hired somebody
rookie or not who had the credentials
and had demonstrated professionalism on
the set then I think that moves him away
from Criminal liability okay Joseph Tony
thank you very much Dave want to bring
in court TV host Julie Grant now also in
the United States uh Julie you've
covered a lot of court cases uh
self-evidently but what do you make of
this and how much Jeopardy is Alec
Baldwin now in
he is in big big trouble peers thank you
so much for having me on your show it's
a real honor and a pleasure to be with
you he is looking at a world of problems
with these charges this has been an
investigation that took so much time I
want to show you something Pierce I have
in my hand just a portion of the
investigation report it's 551 Pages we
know they were investigating since
October of 2021 when poor Helena
Hutchins was killed and this is just a
fraction of that investigative report so
this has been quite thorough a very
weighty decision made by these
prosecutors in Santa Fe New Mexico to
not only announce charges forthcoming
against Alec Baldwin but also against
the armorer and prop Master Hannah
Gutierrez read I am certainly not
surprised at these charges Pierce what
is it to you when you've been through
all this what is it to you that rings
out which may be as if you said by the
prosecutor what is it that brings out
you think which points to negligence by
Alec Baldwin
we had the nail on the head just now by
using that word peers the word
negligence that's what's so key because
I think what's hard for most people to
wrap their minds around when you hear
about this is we all know it was tragic
we know there's been nobody more upset
than Alec Baldwin and Hannah Gutierrez
Reid her attorney just issued a
statement a short time ago saying how
upset she's been since this happened
nobody wanted anyone to be killed so I
think what's hard to understand is that
in America you can face criminal charges
even if you don't have bad intent with
the charges that these two are going to
be facing There's No Malice involved
there's no evil mind or you know
depraved heart no this is just somebody
acting negligently without using do
caution and circumspection doing what a
reasonable person would not have done
under those circumstances so with
something that was accidental something
that's so unfortunate and so tragic
there can still be criminal liability
attached peers yeah and I think there
should be I I I have found Alec
Baldwin's PR tool sickening absolutely
sickening he should have shut his mouth
or waited for the legal process to come
out and said we've had these endless
attempts to distance himself from any
responsibility whatsoever he feels no
guilt I would feel pretty guilty if I
pointed a gun at someone and killed them
even if it was an accident I'd feel
guilty I'd feel like wow I've just
killed somebody but there's nothing not
a shred of that it's all been
self-protective it's all been about
protecting the brand of Alec Baldwin and
I've watched it all on Instagram with
his wife doing the same thing you know
portraying him as a a tormented family
man going through hell on their endless
expensive holidays and so on well fine I
don't want to see it I don't want to
hear it I just want to see the legal
Praises play out and find out exactly
and I think we will do now exactly how
responsible Alec Baldwin was not just as
an actor who didn't check his own gun
before firing it at somebody and
pointing it in a woman's head but also
as a co-producer of a set that appears
to be a total safety shambles and at the
moment he's saying nothing to do with me
gov which I think is completely
unsustainable
um listen Julie thank you very much
great to have you on the show as always
it's been a pleasure talking with you
peers you are right once again you said
many poignant things just now thank you
for having me thanks Judy nice to talk
to you a quick quick reaction from you
Paul if we go to the break I just wanted
to answer both Isabella Richards
question what were we going to get for
this what are they hoping to achieve and
the simple answer is Justice right it's
Justice you know we have accidents in
the workplace all the time that doesn't
mean that they should just be dealt with
as a shrug of the shoulders and let's
not go I agree with you and I think the
problem here for us British viewers as
it were observing this is the word
manslaughter I think the word negligent
and negligence
involuntary man sort of means you didn't
deliberately set out to kill somebody
but they died as a result of your
negligent actions right that's really
what it means remember peers I think a
difficulty that Alec Baldwin is going to
have is also in terms of recklessness
was he Reckless and that's a real
difficult hurdle I think they're going
to face yeah okay let's take a short
break when we come back with more
reaction uh so it's including from Judge
Jeanine Pirro from the Fox News The Five
she'll have strong views on this because
I've heard her expressing before stay
with us
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
culture is at the Oxford Union it's a
surprising ratchet and went viral
globally Constantine Singh joins me live
later in the post
let's get some more reaction now from
Hollywood to this extraordinary news
Alec Baldwin is to be charged with
involuntary manslaughter after the death
of uh one of the cinematographers on his
uh movie set of rust I'm joined now by
the veteran Hollywood Reporter Janine
Wolfe Jenny this is uh look it's a story
that's gripped Hollywood now for 18
months or so what do you make of this
announcement today that he's going to
face charges and How likely do you think
it is that he'll be convicted
these charges were shocking to everybody
no one expected them to come down that
hard on Alec but I think what we've got
here what makes this all confusing is
there's a big mixture between movie
rules and movie procedures and the law
so we think it's an accident nobody
thinks that Alec Baldwin set out to harm
this talented cinematographer on the
other hand uh the district attorney says
yeah but you didn't follow the law and
the chain of command was loose and we
have to place blame
yeah I think that's what it comes down
to I I think that's where if I was his
legal team I'd be pretty concerned about
what that D.A was saying today uh and
what what has been put out there
publicly about why he's facing these
charges produced as well as actor
all right so they a lot of stories have
come out that it wasn't the most
disciplined set and you can always find
uh go back and figure out what went
wrong but but the thing is that uh what
you hear here is nobody is above the law
and they're repeating that over and over
again and what they're saying is Alec
Baldwin may be a big movie star but
that's not how we judge things here and
and that's really unfair in legal terms
prejudicial against him uh the point is
as producer and as actor
you know one Alec may be trying to step
back from those responsibilities but on
the other hand nobody sees this as
anything but a horrible horrific
accident well it is but unfortunately at
the end of the accident somebody died
and there's got to be accountability for
for what led to that death and that is
what we're now going to get from his
courtroom Janine thank you very much
indeed for joining me I appreciate it
well let's go now said Laura Pellegrini
she's a film director and producer in
America who's worked on war movies and
stuff with lots of guns on set so Laura
let me ask you this in terms of the
procedure that goes on on sets when
there are guns and they're supposed to
be firing blanks and so on what is the
procedure I mean it's quite clear Ms D.A
thinks that actually the procedure broke
down and was neglected and that led to
what happened but what's your take of
this
you know it's a it's a great question
and my co-director Stephanie defray and
I have worked on multiple sets where
we've had to handle help actors handle
firearms and essentially what should
have happened is that you have a prop
master and the prop Master is
responsible for firearms on set if
they're used then the fire are then the
prop Master excuse me works
close-handedly with the Firearms
um uh person and and they're the
professional that's tasked with the
responsibility of the gun to make sure
that it's a cold gun not a hot gun and
there's a certain line of command after
that then once the the gun is cleared
it's then handed over to the first
assistant director and the first
assistant director
has the responsibility of declaring that
it's a cold gun before they then hand
off the gun to the actor
so there's clearly a shift in the
sequence of command that happened on set
and I think we're still trying to
determine what went wrong in the
breakdown of that communication what I'm
told and the da also suggested this from
other actors is that they always
themselves would make a final check just
to be sure an Alec Baldwin clearly
hasn't done that here physically himself
with the gun
right and it's a good point that you
bring up and also I'm trying to you know
be a little bit more I guess sympathetic
toward Alec Baldwin's perspective and
that he was co-producer as well as actor
on set so as co-producer he wasn't
tasked necessarily with managing all
aspects of production he has other
producers to help him with that but like
I said there was a breakdown in
communication also during rehearsal
because as we know this happened during
a rehearsal there should be no guns on
set you shouldn't even be rehearsing
with a gun because then that increases
your liability of an accident happening
I might be being rather stupid here
Laura but what is a what is a hot gun
doing anywhere near a movie set anyway
why'd you need a halt gun period it
shouldn't be any it shouldn't be
anywhere near a movie set
um you know certainly on the sets that
Stefano and I work on we just worked on
a World War II film and there were no
hot guns to be found there were no live
rounds on set no ammunition none of that
um but bottom line is especially during
a rehearsal when you're not required to
even be carrying a gun for the scene I
know that they wanted to frame it up and
he was working with Helena to get the
frame right but there's certain things
that you can achieve in post to make
that happen there's certain effects that
you can rely more on post-production to
to create a gun effect and work with CGI
to make that happen there shouldn't have
been anything like that on set I mean my
sort of gut feeling about Alex Morgan
with this is what's really got my gut
about the way he's responded is the
singular lack of any willingness to
admit any thought to himself everyone
else is to blame apart from him and I
think that has probably wound up this
D.A as much as anything else and in a
way this PR campaign may have been the
most self-defeating thing he could
possibly have done
I'm sure I'm sure I think you know Alec
I believe he did himself a disservice in
saying that he didn't pull the trigger
on the gun because then how could there
have been any projectile or any bullet
that reached Helena and and you know the
director of the film it wouldn't be
possible so there were certain things
that he said I believe that might have
been a disservice to that
um but you know bottom line is this is a
senseless tragedy that that could have
been easily avoided had certain
protocols been issued and reinforced on
set okay Laura thank you very much
indeed Laura Pellegrini there who's
worked with a lot of guns on movie sets
and there was anything quite like this
PR expert Mike Paul joins me now from
America
where is Alec Baldwin's career in all
this he's now facing serious criminal
charges we know he pulled the trigger
that killed this poor woman on this set
is he got a career after this
that's an excellent question also a
career that includes talent and
producing has another major question
which is are you insurable
look we also need to remember that only
a few days before this accident
situation happened of which he has
allegations against him that there was a
beef between union workers seeking to be
replaced by non-reunion workers and the
issue was Major safety issues that was
happening on that set Alex also put out
a video only a few days before the
shooting trying to show that he had a
support for the union members who had
some serious allegations I think that's
going to be a narrative that's going to
be added to this trial look for it look
for the narrative to not be Alex and not
be some of the information that we know
to date there's going to be a lot more
detail as to what was the attitude the
facts that were happening before the
shooting
which could be a major factor as to
whether the allegations are going to
stick with Alec both as talent and
producer as we move forward was it a
massive PR owned goal to go on this tour
of self-pity distancing himself from any
responsibility do you think
uh one of the things that is so
important to look at from this
perspective is a bigger question which
is is Alec the type of person who
listens to good advice right he's
certainly got advice that he should not
be doing that he did it and he certainly
got advice that he needs to have his own
security detail he doesn't have it he
has his wife at times doing it for him
which is just nuts to me he has a large
family he does not listen to good advice
that's going to be a major factor in
this trial we've seen that as a major
factor in previous trials too including
the Johnny Depp and Amber Heard trial
she wasn't a good listener let's see if
Alec is going to finally have some
humble tea and start listening to those
experts who he's hiring today
that ship is sailed for him I mean in my
experience of Valley Auburn he's an
arrogant hothead and he responded
exactly how I would have predicted him
to respond which is to lash out and
blame everyone but it's very good
prosecutor and look for a good
prosecutor to utilize exactly what you
just said against Alec because he is
very sore skin and you can easily turn
to anger my Paul thank you very much
indeed I appreciate it well I'm joined
Now by Judge Jeanine pero from the Five
on Fox News the Smash It show uh judge I
don't know about you I'm absolutely
raging about Alec Baldwin generally at
the best of times I just felt that his
his extraordinary self-pitying tool to
try and distance himself from
accountability on this it may actually
have backfired and led to this D.A
wanting to nail him
but you know peers I just interviewed
the D.A on the case and I don't think
there's anything that motivated her
other than the evidence in this case but
as it relates to what you said in your
comment I agree with you the fact that
this guy Alec Baldwin thinks he's so
important that he's going to go out
there and tell the world that he didn't
do anything that he never pulled a
trigger would never point a gun at
anyone and pull the trigger that is and
you know I ran the DA's office I was the
D.A I mean for you know three decades uh
that that is what any D.A looks for in
terms of evidence it is an inconsistent
statement that the D.A made clear is
contradicted by the FBI forensic
evidence when you've got a Colt 45
single action you do not it does not go
off unless you put your finger on that
trigger it is a single action firearm
and his arrogance and and you know
you'll see on the the five today my
interview of them and I think that the
most interesting answer that the D.A
gave me had to do with the fact when I
asked her you know did Baldwin cooperate
with you and uh she was very very
hesitant in her description and I
referenced there when she wanted his
phone when it first came out that he
directed his assistant to uh get rid of
the archives of messages so we've got a
guy who's arrogant he's condescending
but that's not the basis for the charge
the basis for the charge Piers is that
he took a weapon he pointed a weapon at
a human being and he pulled the trigger
and he did so to a mother in the prime
of her life and she lost her life now I
don't care if you're on a movie set or
on the Avenue of the Americas outside
where I am right now you do not do that
and the fact that he's charged only with
involuntary manslaughter he is
consistent with the law but there is an
upward sentencing there if they
determine and this is up to the jury
that the use of the gun was a part of it
so he faces up to six and a half years
wow I didn't know that uh and Santa Fe
you're going to get a jury that will be
familiar with guns many of them will own
guns themselves we'll have a view about
it yeah and they'll have a view about
gun safety generally what is clear from
this set was that the safety was a
shambles you had people already walking
off set in protest at the lack of safety
you've got a very young armorer who was
just 24 years old very inexperienced but
my question was Remains the most
perplexing thing what were they doing
with a hot gun anyway in terms of
potentially having one why would he have
to ask is it hot or cold how could that
even be a question and why would any
live ammunition be anywhere near a movie
set
and that's precisely the issue appears
and you understand that that any move a
movie set that has live ammo on the set
is is negligent as far as I'm concerned
per se but don't take my word for it the
truth is and I asked the D.A about this
in my interview the truth is that not
only was it an unsafe set there were the
there were two live rounds that went off
and this the armorer whose charged as
Hannah guaterra's read I was 24 years
old who never should have applied for
the job because she herself admitted she
didn't have the experience but her
father was famous and therefore uh
Baldwin said you know I'll save money
here and the D.A was very clear the D.A
said money was more important than
safety on this set but when a live round
went off and she knew it and workers
were walking off this set they said it
was unsafe at that point you have to be
you have to be an idiot to not
understand
that you've got Guns live ammunition
live rounds going off and you're
pointing a gun and pulling a trigger
come on this is an idiot oh you have to
be an arrogant a Hollywood movie star
with a hot head which is what we know
Alec Baldwin is uh judge thank you so
much for taking the time I know you're
flat out today including on the five
you'll be thrilled to hear I'll be
joining you on the five in a month time
again uh it's one of the joys of my life
working with you on that occasionally
and ours as well cheers we look forward
to it take care Justin thank you very
much for taking my time I appreciate it
thank you my pleasure well coming up
next I'm joined by the British comedian
whose evisceration of woke culture
ignited the Oxford Union and actually he
almost won over most of the students and
he went viral around the world
Constantine Gibson joins me next
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
what out of a rare victory for free
speech comedian and author Constantine
kissing went viral after taking on woke
culture and an Oxford Union speech Let's
have a look at some of the highlights
this country is responsible for two
percent of global carbon emissions which
means that if Britain was to sink into
the sea right now it would make
absolutely no difference to the issue of
climate change you know why because the
future of the climate is going to be
decided in Asia and in Latin America by
poor people who couldn't give about
saving the planet there is only one
thing we can do in this country to stop
climate change and that is to make
scientific and technological
breakthroughs that will create the clean
energy that is not only clean but also
cheap and the only thing that wokeness
has to offer in exchange is to brainwash
Bright Young Minds like you to believe
that you are victims to believe that you
have no agency to believe that what you
must do to improve the world is to
complain
is to protest is to throw soup on
paintings
we know that the way to improve the
world is to work is to create it is to
build
and the problem with work culture is
that it's trained too many young minds
like yours
to forget about that
[Applause]
yes the slow hand clap that's what every
comedian works
let me do it faster
um I've done Nelson Union tough crowd
normally but you actually want a lot of
them over they were quite respectful uh
and I think I was probably a bit
surprised by the response uh it's gone
viral Global this all over America as
well because it really resonated with
people I think rather like me where you
know I'm not right wing I'm not
left-wing I'm kind of slightly Center I
guess politically about stuff a liberal
more than not but I find this Ultra woke
mentality so illiberal that it borders
on the very fascism they profess to hate
most so to see you go into the lion's
den a bit with all these woke students
and actually what I thought was
impressive about it Constantine was the
way you didn't demonize them and maybe
that is the way to to progress and get
this woke nonsense dealt with properly
is that you don't demonize them you
actually show them a better way I think
so and like you I identify as
politically non-binary peers and and so
that that's angle I was approaching from
look the fact is both you and I know
that when we were 18 20 we were idiots
as well and we were very cocky and sure
of ourselves and we thought we knew the
answers to everything what we didn't
have was the internet to brainwash us
and we didn't have this very powerful
ideology actually wokeness is an
ideology and there's some very strong
Concepts behind it but that all aside
and I thought I found that I had a very
interesting encounter because you you
did you once have seen this but we had
to wait quite a long time before the
debate started and I actually was
talking to one of the students in the
bar and she she couldn't believe that I
even thought the woke people existed
like to her this was unicorns but she
came up to me after the debate and asked
for a selfie and that's kind of what I
thought really summed up the whole
experience we've got to remember these
are young people in the mind they're
open to persuasion we got to make better
arguments and I think antagonizing
people and we've all been there you and
I and everything else you know my
journey with my show trigonometry it's
been an evolution too yeah I haven't
started out like this necessarily but
what I've come to now and maybe it's
being a father of a young child now as
well I'm starting to see that you know
these are kids and we we have a
responsibility to persuade them to
convince them with rational argument and
look when you're speaking to Bright
people like the ones at Oxford you've
got a chance I mean one of the worst
aspects of wokory is the way that people
now feel too afraid to express opinions
and it's becoming a real thing where
people you know I name Joan Collins on
it didn't want to say what she thought a
woman was and she's one of my favorite
people in the world Joan and obviously
knows what she believes a woman is but
didn't want to raise her head over a
parabit just to be shot down by the
trans Lobby or whatever whatever Lobby
it may be at any given moment there's
this mob mentality you if you don't
agree with me you must be canceled
immediately shame vilified JK Rowling
whoever it may be
how we got to this place what's fueling
it how do we deal with it well first of
all I know that you're shocked by and I
think a lot of people in the west are
shocked but actually as someone who grew
up in the Soviet Union this is very
familiar I mean this is exactly what we
had and that's one of the reasons I'm in
this country is my grandfather said the
wrong thing and was forced into Exile so
this is actually if you think about
human history pretty standard we just
didn't expect it to be happening in the
21st century and I think technology is a
big part of it social media allows
people to mob other people well the
fuels also tribalism it fuels this sort
of righteous indignation the victimhood
people don't forget there's also oh
there's real power and the power
actually manifests itself from the mob
going to corporate world and demanding
that they fire people and get rid of
people who don't agree with their view
exactly and I think a lot of people
particularly and you know this isn't an
attack but you know if you don't have a
lot of meaning in your own life this is
a way to get some meaning because you
tap this thing on your phone or on your
keyboard and suddenly a famous person's
getting canceled I think that's a big
part of it but as I say I'm just you'd
frankly point out I think the solution
here is to be reasonable to talk to
people to try and persuade them while
also of course we've got to stand up and
not allow these cancellations to happen
and that means that you know TV
producers and big corporations they have
to step up as well I mean I was forced
out of my last job for disbelieving Mega
Mark which seems Preposterous now given
the nonsense that comes out of her mouth
but that showed me that when the mob
attacked the corporate world the
corporate world will often bow to the
Mob because actually they're just
terrified of the consequences the
terrified of losing advertising Revenue
sponsors and so on that's the way they
do it it's very well marshaled and when
organized albeit there are quite a small
number of people they're just well
organized yeah and they're able to
create the illusion that there is lots
of them because on social media you can
get a lot of traction with with not a
lot but I think you're right and I think
the fact is that we're building an
alternative ecosystem now shows like
mine on YouTube and uh there's going to
be companies that are making products
that don't care if you're woke or not
advertisers that are not interested did
in this stuff and I actually said this
on Twitter today I think the future
isn't woke or anti-work the Futures post
work we just got to move past this well
the trouble is the word has become toxic
originally work meant that you were just
more alert to racial and social
injustice yeah or we would all sign up
to that anyone with a brain and a
conscience would say yeah I can sign up
to it but it's been hijacked yes by the
ultra wokies you basically are a former
fascist who are using this for their own
ends and I think that's why both all of
us are actually just got to move past it
and go this has appeared in human
history which was pretty stupid let's
move on let's see how we can work
together and but for peace we've got to
change the way that we have political
conversations in this country because
that's where this polarization is coming
from and we carry on down this path it's
very dangerous well that's so tribal as
well and toxic and Hyper partisan fueled
Again by social media people don't want
to admit anything wrong with their side
right and it's so refreshing when
occasionally you hear one of them do it
you know you think wow there's someone
prepared to criticize their own side as
if it's somehow a football team and you
can't admit to giving a way of booking
or something why yeah how do we get to
that place in the Democracy the whole
point of democracy is that actually we
have a debate and we reach consensus
well right and that's why I quite often
do is my audience grows and expands I go
out of my way to annoy some of them to
just kind of position myself correctly
because I don't want to be playing to
any Eco chamber I'm trying to just be
honest about what I think
trigonometry and you're going to go
gangbusters on the back of this viral
clip I mean you're surprised by how it's
taken off I mean it's going to sound
arrogant but I'm not I felt pretty good
on the night particularly you know no
notice I noticed yeah well yeah I I
can't I'm pretty clear on what I think
about it now you know we spend five
years on trigonometry interviewing all
sorts of Fascinating People you know the
Douglas Murray's the Jordan Petersons
lots of people on the left trying to
understand what's going on because you
know the story of us is it's two
comedians didn't really know what was
going on but what we felt was in comedy
there was a lot of hypersensitivity and
outright censorship going on we can
understand where it was coming from so
we thought let's talk to people who are
smarter than us who can explain what's
going on and now I'm pretty clear on
what I think well you've been trying to
get me on trigonometry for a while when
are you coming now I will now publicly
agree and we're going to do it at our
mutual friends restaurant in Portugal in
Kensington Saturday I'll be there let's
put the world to rights Constantine
congratulations on a brilliant speech
and I'll see you there
well next tonight New York Republican
George Santos the congressman has denied
being a drag queen 15 years ago but why
would anyone believe it you may not have
heard of this guy but he's probably the
biggest liar in the history of global
politics and I'm going to show you how
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
with this one because Tottenham Hotspur
had beating Manchester City 2-0 which is
great for Arsenal except we hate toddler
so a bit of mixed feed my dad's a Spurs
fans I suppose on this one occasion to
say all right Dad I'm happy for you uh
well welcome back um now look we're
familiar with political Fibbers in the
UK Boris Johnson lied more often than he
tried but New York Republican
Congressman George Santos might just be
the biggest liar in the history of
global politics today he angrily denied
a bizarre plausible claim if you know
much about Mr Santos and he competed as
a drag queen in a Brazilian beauty
pageant and the reason people don't
believe him is that Pinocchio Santos has
a rap sheet of Whoppers which is quite
staggering he claimed for example to
have gone to various schools none of
which he actually went to he said he
graduated in the top one percent of his
class in 2010 with degree in economics
and finance he didn't he said he worked
at Goldman Sachs and Citigroup he didn't
his lives ain't got more serious in July
2021 he said that in the 9 11 attacks
his mother had died and said she'd be
working in her office in the South Tower
his mother died from cancer in 2016.
there's no evidence she ever worked at
the World Trade Center he claimed his
grandparents survived the Holocaust of
persecution during World War II they
didn't he said he's Jewish he's not he
said he lost 400 employees and the
horrific Pulse Nightclub mass shooting
in 2016. he didn't
it's honestly staggering how many lies
this guy has told and yet tonight he
remains a serving sitting U.S
congressman and for that George Santos
you are my douche of the day let's go
back to the pack Paula Richard and
Isabel I mean he is honestly the number
of Lies it's about twice as long as that
that's just an edited version of a
column I wrote for the New York Post
system I thought even though many people
in the UK may not have heard of him when
you hear that you're just like what
how's this guy a congressman it's
absolutely jaw-dropping even Donald
Trump though wow this guy's got a got a
problem with truth it's extraordinary
and what lies did he tell to get elected
apart from those well he's in one of the
New York Third District and the reason
he got elected was they were so
desperate to get rid of the Democrats
and part of it is Queens which is
Trump's older home Borough and that they
basically he had trumpian policies he
believes the 2020 election was stolen so
he sort of won the trump vote if you
like but it's just staggering that he
could lie that brazenly about absolutely
everything including 911 but it'll also
do a motive issue in America and he's
sitting there in Congress it's
unbelievable but it's also a real test
actually for the House of
Representatives because they do have a
mechanism to remove what is it very
rarely used it's article one section
five I think I've got that right get me
hey I've been doing my research yeah um
and if 2 3
house vote to expel him then he's been
expelled right but it's hardly ever and
here's the problem Paula in America as
in Britain the partisan nature of
politics is so toxic now and so
absolutely embedded that there'll be no
will of the Republicans to take a chance
on doing this so they won't even put it
forward and this is the thing and this
is what worries me the most about this
story and I know that we're making light
of it and laughing about it it's
actually not that funny
grotesque because it it includes it's
just unbelievable in terms of the voters
as well what are they seeing the voters
they are seeing the fact that this man
who hasn't lied for the first time in a
couple of weeks or in the last few
months or in the last few years
he didn't even call himself George
Santos yeah until recently he's had a
number
various pseudonyms I mean the guy is not
even who he says he is
this time being supported by the
Republican party it does show the contra
us with British politics because I can't
think of a politician here being able to
get away with one of those Boris has
tried let's be honest um let's just turn
to wokery
I don't understand that well you do
understand it no I genuinely don't
you're gonna have to Define it I wrote a
book about it and the truth is that what
woke the woke culture began in the 60s
uh actually in American black music was
where it originated and it meant having
a greater awareness of Social and racial
Injustice I signed up to that I think we
all would exactly today has become a new
form of left-wing fascism no it has
happened no what has happened today is
that
I hate using this term left wing and
right wing but if you force me to the
right side of the argument has decided
that they are going to grab hold of a
word that is synonymous with kindness
and and patience and thoughtfulness
wake up and attempt to use there's
nothing kind or tolerant or patient
the word woke the people who now put the
argument we will have a decent
you put the word
the people you're talking about who call
themselves proudly awoken their social
media bios and have hashtag become
they're the least tolerant least kind
least patient most vile intransigent
canceled culture Merchants you would
ever meet
they call themselves liberals reference
the argument to them reference the
specific argument to them this is not
about being woke because you have just
explained and for some viewers first
time what woke means and they will be
surprising we've got to move to this
we've all signed up to it's a more
important thing than this which is this
uh Shakira starma was asked a big
question today labor leader here's a
question here's the answer
you're an Arsenal fan
I'm going to give you two the names of
two die-hard Arsenal fans and you've got
to who choose who you'd rather sit next
to
Piers Morgan or Jeremy corbyn Piers
Morgan
that was quick that was quick that was
very quick
yeah the current labor leader would
rather sit next to me at an Arsenal game
than the ex-leader of the party that he
replaced I think he knows he's got eight
million followers on Twitter and if
you're that big a fan of me he's secure
when are you coming on Piers Morgan
uncensored because it's been eight
months and we haven't seen you yet so
come on goona to goona come and sit down
here and be interviewed by me great to
see you Pat what are you making about I
mean he could have just played the easy
card and said of course Jeremy Corbett
he didn't he went Morgan oh he wanted to
be provocative I mean without question I
think he was just telling the truth I'd
rather sit next to you than Jeremy you
actually have sat next to me at Arsenal
game
in the very smart seats in the very
smart I found you in the most expensive
seats I didn't pay was that not kissed
armor saying goodbye once and for all to
the Jeremy corbyn support I think it was
actually I actually think it was and on
Sunday I also have a massive game
against Manchester United he of course
cruelly ditched my friend Chris John
Ronaldo who tonight scored two goals in
Saudi Arabia he beat uh Lionel Messi's
goal tally for the night he got mad of
the match that's my man Arsenal and my
team come Sunday we're gonna win we're
gonna go 11 points clear good night Keep
It Uncensored have a great weekend
Causeway uh come on arsenal
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you